ah
[Música]
california apenas hizo acto de presencia
en este último debate presidencial tan
solo muy de pasada cuando otro hampa
aseguró que la mayor parte de los
estados demócratas han tenido un mayor
número de muertes a consecuencia del cob
hidalgo que al menos en el caso de
california no es cierto de hecho este
estado ha logrado reabrir buena parte de
su economía sin que hayan aumentado el
número de muertes en los últimos meses
bueno uno de los temas principales de
este debate fue sobre todo el tema de la
pandemia y con lo que los candidatos
piensan hacer ante una posible tercera
ola otros temas que también se
debatieron fueron inmigración tensión
racial y sobre todo también posibles
injerencias de potencias extranjeras
sobre todo de rusia y de china en las
elecciones algo que trump desmintió pero
sobre todo lo que marcó este debate es
que no hubo la misma cantidad de
interrupciones que durante el primero y
es que la amenaza de cerrar de cortar
los micrófonos si los candidatos se
pasaban de tiempo pareció surtir efecto
[Música]
ambos partidos se encaran la recta final
de la campaña presidencial con una
mirada puesta en florida el presidente
el republicano donald trump tiene varios
actos en florida a un estado clave para
su reelección quiere asegurarse los
votos de los indecisos que van a ser los
que tengan la llave para decidir quién
va a ocupar la casa blanca en los
próximos cuatro años el presidente
también aprovecha que este fin de semana
está en florida para ejercer su voto
anticipado un mecanismo que permite a
los electores ejercer su derecho al voto
hasta dos semanas antes del día de la
elección que es el 3 de noviembre por su
parte la campaña demócrata continúa
intensificando sus esfuerzos en este
estado también necesita el apoyo de las
minorías como los hispanos y los
afroamericanos el ex presidente barack
obama confirmó que al igual que trump va
a estar este fin de semana en florida
pero con un acto en miami las encuestas
también tienen su protagonismo en la
última semana de campaña electoral los
demócratas siguen liderando las
encuestas en todo el país incluso en
florida pero ni baide ni trump se
quieren confiar de los
[Música]
tres escándalos hacen parte de esta
carrera por llegar a la casa blanca esta
semana a menos de dos semanas de las
elecciones presidenciales el primero
tiene que ver con el presidente de
donald trump y su declaración de
impuestos según el diario the new york
times entre el año 2013 a 2015 el
presidente de trump habría pagado más
impuestos en china que en los eeuu el
segundo escándalo tiene que ver con su
política de inmigración y es que más de
500 niños que están en centros de
detención en la frontera sur de los eeuu
no han podido ser reunidos con sus
padres después de la política de
separación de familias del mandatario lo
que ha generado fuertes críticas hacia
el presidente por parte de
organizaciones que defienden los
derechos humanos y el tercer escándalo
tiene que ver con el candidato demócrata
joe var en el presidente de donald trump
asegura que tiene pruebas para mostrar
que hayden cuando era vicepresidente
habría favorecido los intereses
comerciales de su hijo con el gobierno
de china
[Música]